في علم الاخلاق يكون دائما الفضيله وبين
فضيلين احنا لا نريد ان نكون متبلدين
اجامدين او او والله خارجين عن سر بنا لا
لكن لا نريد اشخاص يستغرقون في الامور
واحيانا نقول والله
يتوحدون مع احيانا في بعض الامور وبعض
الاشياء
المرحله الملكيه همم جمالها انك ستعطي
اكثر علاقاتك ستكون افضل لانك لن تكون
يعني بذاكر العتب او اللوم او التدقيق على
اخر المرحله الملكيه معناها انك والله
تجعل مساحه معينه انت متنازل عنها وهذه
الحقيقه وهذا الحقيقه احنا احنا بشر لا
ننشد حلولا كامله في وسط غير كامل فهذه
تجعلك معارك تنتقيها
في في احيانا بعض الناس يعني خذ معارك
والله لا تقدم ولا تاخر ويرمي بكل ما لديك
الان نحن في العصر السوشيال ميديا حلو انا
الان احد الاشخاص الذين لي وجود في
السوشيال ما شاء الله عليكم وانت كذلك هل
عدمت اخ خالد يوم من الايام اتاتن مختبن
خلف الكيبورد ويعطيك شيئا من الكلام
القاسي او النقد الجارح هذه هذه انا انا
لو تورطت معه واستدرجني في ساحته زي ربما
لا مو ربما جزما سيغلبني زين وايضا يعني
مجهود شوف شوف نحن طاقات طاقه هذه يا انك
توجهها لحياتك لمشاريعكك او توجهها للممثل
هذه الامور ولازم والله كل كل كل معركه
نتوقف عنده كل انسان لابد اتوقع في مرحله
هذه ثم انتقل المعارك وتنتقي بعض الاشخاص
تكون صريح معك اكون صريح معك انا لا
يشرفني ان اكون معه في ساحه واحده
هذا الشخص الذي يختبئ الذي يسب ويشتم ولا
تعرف من يكون زين او الشخص الذي والله
احيانا يعني يقول يهجم عليك هجوما صارخا
وينفسه ويفر عليك
يهاجمك يعني ما شاء الله كل
متابعينك اراهم ايجابيه
في كتاباتك على السوشيال ميديا بشكل عام
يعني انا ما شفت شفت يا اخي
منهم خير مني
مع السلامه لا منك لهذا طبع الحياه وهذه
الثنائيه موجوده جدا جدا وان كنتم يعني قد
ربما اقله من بعض الذين ياخذني ان انا
ناخذه في مواضيع عامه مالي والله في الذي
يتنازعوا او ينقسموا عليها الناس انا
مواضيع يا اما